c'est l'heure de notre second débat avec
cette question faut-il inscrire le droit
à l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
dans la Constitution oui on aurait pu
ont répondu les sénateurs hier soir tout
en remplaçant le mot droit par le mot
liberté c'est important retour sur une
séance historique avec Marion Delpech
pour 166 contre 152 l'amendement est
adopté
[Applaudissements]
plus de peu à 14 fois près pour que le
Sénat rentre cet instant historique
ouvrir la porte au droit de l'IVG dans
la Constitution une victoire pour toutes
les sensibilités politiques de gauche au
départ peu convaincu par un amendement
de compromis l'IVG n'est pas seulement
une liberté pour nous c'est un droit
mais cette rédaction proposée à la vertu
de s'engager sur le chemin de la
constitutionnalisation et au fond
rappelons-nous que la première loi
veille n'a pu être adoptée que grâce à
un travail transpartisan et à la
participation des groupes parlementaires
de la gauche qui avait accepté de larges
concession à l'origine du nouvel
amendement le sénateur Philippe Bas
ancien collaborateur de Simone Veil qui
aurait donc réussi à convaincre une
partie de son camp opposé à la
constitutionnalisation pour le symbole
j'ai simplement
rédiger une contre-proposition à celle
qui venait de la gauche de la France
insoumise pour un texte que je crois
consensuel puisqu'il s'appuie sur le
consensus de la société française sur la
loi veille la liberté de la femme
enceinte de mettre fin à sa grossesse et
la protection de l'enfant à naître sur
ce sujet qui traverse les clivages
partisan les explications de vote ce
sont multipliées faisant craindre à la
sénatrice socialiste Laurence Rossignol
en report du vote car les débats étaient
limités dans le temps fait extrêmement
rare la science a été interrompue par
l'éruption de militantes féministes dans
l'hémicycle la séance est suspendue
quelques minutes avant que l'amendement
ne soit adopté mais la route est encore
longue et incertaine avant la
concrétisation
faut-il constitutionnaliser le droit à
l'avortement en en débat tout de suite
avec mes invités Marie-Pierre de la
Gonterie bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
sénatrice socialiste de Paris et membre
de la commission des lois au Sénat
Charlène bézina bonsoir
constitutionnaliste bienvenue à vous
mettre le conférence en droit public
Jean-Philippe de rosier bonsoir bonsoir
bienvenue constitutionnaliste et
professeur de droit constitutionnel à
l'Université de Lille et Mathilde
Sirault est évidemment resté à mes côtés
je rappelle quelques quelques chiffres
pour commencer source Direction de la
recherche des études de l'évaluation et
des statistiques l'adresse 223 300
interruptions volontaires de grossesse
en France en 2021 et puis cet autre
information une femme sur trois à
recours à une IVG au cours de sa vie
Marie-Pierre de la Gontrie on va
évidemment
consacrer quasiment l'intégralité de ce
débat à la question de la
constitutionnalisation mais quand même
un mot des moyens pour commencer c'est
français qui veulent avorter est-ce
qu'elles peuvent vraiment le faire pas
toujours et c'est des scandales
aujourd'hui
et la détresse de ces femmes c'est à
dire que il y a des territoires où il
n'y a pas de possibilités d'avoir de
trouver le médecin et puis il y a
parfois aussi des des manœuvres
dilatoires
par rapport à cela alors ce sujet ce
problème n'est pas nouveau mais nous
l'avons dit tout au long des débats tout
le monde en est d'accord une chose est
de constitutionnaliser les vigiles d'en
protéger la la légalité une autre enfin
voilà
constitutionnalise qu'il faut non et
soit donner plus moyen le problème de
l'accès à l'IVG nous nous souhaitions
d'ailleurs qui est aussi l'accès à la
contraception simplement en
constitutionnalisant mais mais le sujet
il est là c'est à dire qu'il y a encore
des femmes qui aujourd'hui sont mal
informés sont délibérément désinformés
qui ne trouvent pas de médecins qui etc
oui bien sûr
remonte à la loi veille janvier 75 elle
a été plusieurs fois
réformé amender dans quel sens dans le
sens du droit des femmes c'est assez
clair c'est une tendance régulière on
peut dire ça comme ça
elle est prenante et que finalement
toutes les révisions n'arrivent pas
forcément toujours à solutionner ce
problème
identitaire en fait avec ce droit là
c'est à dire que non seulement il faut
le proclamer non seulement il faut qu'il
existe dans d'autres systèmes juridiques
mais encore faut-il ensuite qu'il
devienne effectif c'est-à-dire un peu la
cause de tous les droits c'est-à-dire
les constitutionnaliser les proclamer
c'est une chose mais arriver à les
pratiquer en société c'est encore
différent oui pour répondre à la
question bien sûr on est plutôt allé
vers des avancées la
constitutionnalisation c'est encore une
étape bien différente sur laquelle
évidemment on va revenir mais mais oui
on peut pas dire qu'il y ait de
véritables menaces à l'heure actuelle
sur le système français du principe même
de l'avortement mais encore une fois
c'est une question moyen et c'est
peut-être aussi une question d'influence
extérieure c'est vrai qu'on voit pas mal
de repli conservateurs de repli un peu
nationaliste avec des tendances qui qui
peuvent parfois donner l'impression que
même les plus fondamentaux des acquis de
l'État de droit peuvent être remises en
cause qui font aussi qu'on réfléchit à
des éléments qui certes font déjà partie
de nos lois mais sur lesquels on a
besoin d'une réflexion supplémentaire en
tant que peuple finalement dans une
interview au magazine Le Point c'était
au mois de novembre dernier à propos de
cette inscription de du droit à l'IVG
dans la Constitution vous vous répondiez
ne soumettons pas la Constitution à des
phénomènes de mode c'était même le titre
de l'article pourquoi alors le titre de
l'article c'est pas moi qui l'ai écrit
de votre interview alors ma première
préoccupation est effectivement que
lorsque l'on modifie la Constitution on
le fasse après une réflexion mûrie et je
crois que dans le cas présent on est
dans le cadre d'une réflexion mûrie on a
se lance pas immédiatement dans un dans
un phénomène de mode ma deuxième
préoccupation quand on quand on touche à
la Constitution et en particulier sur
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
c'est que on ne réagisse pas
on s'enrûment au moment où les
États-Unis éternuent donc vous dites il
y a eu la décision américaine et donc on
se réveille et donc tout d'un coup cette
décision de la Cour suprême justifie que
nous on constitutionnalise alors que
nous avons des cultures politiques
juridiques et constitutionnelles
nettement différente que la garantie du
recours à l'avortement que ce soit
liberté ou droit en tout cas la
possibilité pour une femme d'interrompre
volontairement sa grossesse connaît des
garanties juridiques nettement
différentes aux États-Unis et en France
et que le débat de société est
totalement différent maintenant je
trouve que effectivement le débat
constitutionnel est toujours bon sur
quelques questions que ce soit c'est
important de débattre de la Constitution
et que la solution qui a été trouvée
hier soir me paraît une solution
équilibrée entre la volonté de souscrire
à un phénomène de mode en plaçant au
frontispies de la Constitution le droit
à l'avortement et
inscrire de reconnaître dans la
Constitution la liberté de la femme
n'aviron propriétaire
droit on y reviendra dans ce débat ma
Marie Pierre de la contrée vous voulez
réagir évidemment oui parce que ce n'est
pas parce qu'on en parle aujourd'hui que
pour autant il faut réduire le combat
des associations féministes et des
féministes à cet effet de mode s'il est
exact que la décision américaine a fait
prendre conscience je pense à l'ensemble
des Français et des Françaises en
l'occurrence
qu'il y avait toujours un risque dans
les pays
développés voilà que finalement la cause
des femmes pouvaient bon mais en réalité
24 juin dernier la décision de la Cour
suprême qui revient sur sur le mouvement
en Europe
a été entamé moi je ne sais pas si vous
en rappelez mais rappelez-vous il y a
exactement 10 ans lorsque l'Espagne
décide c'était à l'époque
souhaitent revenir sur sur le droit
l'avortement et puis des manifestations
massives etc et retour en arrière donc
il y a toute une série de pays en Europe
et tout à coup on est quand même obligé
de regarder à nos frontières et se dire
que la France n'est pas un î protéger
donc
les formations politiques et les
féministes se battent depuis longtemps
là-dessus il y a des propositions de loi
qui sont anciennes donc tout à coup tout
le monde a pris conscience au moment de
la décision américaine qui honnêtement a
quand même voilà indépendamment des
systèmes juridiques des systèmes de
santé etc donc ça c'est une bonne chose
vous savez moi je l'ai cité en ouverture
de mon intervention hier et cette phrase
de Simone de Beauvoir qui dit voilà
c'est à dire qu'il suffira d'une crise
politique religieuse économique pour que
les droits des femmes reculent soyez
toujours vigilante et ça je pense qu'il
faut en être conscient et moi je le fais
avec les jeunes générations qui parfois
se disent mais pourquoi elle nous dit ça
c'est à dire que rien n'est jamais
acquis concernant les droits des femmes
alors effectivement le débat hier soir
et en rentrant dans le détail c'était
entre le droit ou la liberté ce premier
février il restera historique dans
l'histoire parlementaire le Sénat
majoritairement de droite a donc voté
les termes c'est la liberté de la femme
pour mettre fin à sa grossesse on va
voir le les votes
318 votes exprimés 166% 52 contre en
octobre il y avait eu une première
proposition qui était passée devant le
devant le Sénat et la droite avait fait
échouer le texte cette fois-ci on l'a
entendu dans le sujet d'ouverture c'est
un amendement du sénateur LR Philippe
bac a fait basculer la majorité donc
plus qu'un droit à l'IVG il parle de
liberté je vous propose qu'il y a une
réaction celle de la sénatrice
écologiste Mélanie Vogel qui défend qui
portait ce texte et qui défend la
constitutionnalisation depuis longtemps
la formulation de philiba elle entérine
ce qu'on sait depuis de nombreuses
années qui est que il est de du domaine
de la loi de pouvoir légiférer sur
l'avortement et elle laisse énormément
de liberté au législateur pour
déterminer les conditions et puis elle
parle de liberté et non pas de droit et
il y a une différence importante
juridique c'est qu'un droit ça implique
que l'État vous doit quelque chose pour
que vous puissiez accéder à ce droit
alors qu'une liberté elle est inhérente
à votre personne et au fond on vous doit
juste de ne pas vous empêcher de
l'exercer anne-charley bizina droit ou
liberté évidemment les mots ont un sens
mais juridiquement les conséquences sont
sont pas les mêmes c'est ça il y a
plusieurs choses déjà sur le plan
théorique qu'est-ce que c'est un droit
par rapport à une liberté la liberté
c'est la liberté de faire la liberté
finalement de ne pas être entravée dans
l'exercice du liberté liberté
d'expression liberté individuelle dans
lesquelles en fait c'est pas tellement
l'interlocuteur qui est présent c'est la
liberté le droit ça va être le droit a
c'est à dire alors souvent même si
évidemment il y a toujours des nuances
entre les consommer on va plutôt penser
aux droits créances et a finalement une
obligation de la part de l'état de vous
garantir l'exercice de ce droit à droite
grève droit même à l'environnement sain
ces dernières années et donc c'est vrai
que parfois on pouvait être gêné par la
formulation d'un droit à l'IVG qui en
soit d'ailleurs est un peu revendicatif
et qui n'est pas forcément toujours en
correspondance avec ce droit à l'IVG que
finalement les femmes pratiquent ou
égard à une liberté personnelle et qui
n'attendent pas qu'on est une quelconque
garantie médicale de ces questions il y
a des questions de semaine il y a des
questions finalement médicales qui
rentrent en jeu donc c'est bien plus la
disposition de son corps qui était
importante je pense à
constitutionnaliser que la question du
droit a donc au fond première chose
c'est cette distinction qui toutefois
existe mais deuxième est-ce que la
première formulation était vraiment très
différente de la deuxième moi ça je n'en
suis pas certaine étant donné que la loi
devait déjà garantir l'exercice du droit
a donc en fait on revenait sur l'idée
que la loi avait la compétence pour le
régime et dans le pire des cas où nous
reviendrions un système autoritaire qui
souhaiterait restreindre ce droit et
bien tout le loisir lui était déjà donné
avec la formulation de l'Assemblée
nationale de le restreindre ce droit
donc je ne suis pas sûr qu'on soit allé
plus ou moins loin avec la garantie
sénatoriale mais c'est vrai qu'en termes
lexical et par rapport aussi à ce que ça
signifie par rapport à la liberté de la
femme peut-être que cette formulation
c'est les renatoriale me semble être
plus en correspondance avec ceux à quoi
on s'attend pour une
constitutionnalisation
un peu dubitatif
non non mais je suis pas convaincu c'est
là que je rejoins un challenge busina
sur sa conclusion je suis pas convaincu
qu'il y a une différence fondamentale
entre droit et liberté premièrement il
n'y a pas de hiérarchie entre les
différentes règles constitutionnelles et
c'est pas parce que il y en a qui on
parle de droit qui serait plus important
que d'autres où l'on parle de liberté la
liberté d'expression c'est bien une
liberté c'est l'un des principes
constitutionnels les plus cardinaux
reconnus comme tel temps par la
déclaration de 89 que par le Conseil
constitutionnel qui lorsque il doit
justement pondérer différentes règles
constitutionnelles cherchent plutôt à
préserver cette liberté d'expression
maintenant effectivement dans notre
culture et même j'allais dire jargon
juridique on distingue le droit de le
droit a la liberté mais cela suppose en
effet différents régimes juridiques mais
pas nécessairement différentes
différences de degrés de leur garantie
constitutionnelle lorsque l'on parle
constitutionnel
si on si on avait mis le droit est-ce
que ça on revient la question des moyens
est-ce que ça n'oblige pas l'état à
mettre plus de moyens pour que ce doigt
soit respecté ça change pas en fait non
parce que au niveau constitutionnel
effectivement il y a le sujet des moyens
de
contraceptifs les moyens de pouvoir
interrompre sa grossesse c'est un autre
sujet mais qui ne me semble pas relever
de la conception c'est la loi qui
définit absolument et c'est une
politique publique de que de qu'il faut
encourager ou que certains considérons
qu'il ne faut pas encourager ce qui
était important c'était la
reconnaissance constitutionnelle de la
possibilité de l'existence donc voir
interrompre volontairement sa grossesse
et que l'on en fasse une liberté de la
femme un droit ou un droit a je pense
que il n'y a pas de différence quant à
la reconnaissance et la valeur
constitution et pourtant politiquement
Marie-Pierre de la Gonterie cet
amendement il a fait bouger les lignes
on peut on peut le vote d'octobre et
celui de d'hier soir c'est terrible il y
avait deux niveaux d'analyse mais ça a
été parfaitement expliqué il n'est pas
certain que le terme droit
accorde plus de droits c'est le cas de
le dire que le terme liberté mais
ça chariait une histoire politique une
histoire de revendications différents
c'est-à-dire le droit des femmes de
disposer à disposer de leur corps etc
donc nous nous étions attachés au terme
droit sans faire de droit c'est le cas
de le dire ou plus exactement en tirant
le plus possible l'analyse après
nous savions que pour des raisons sans
doute symétriques
de l'amendement ne souhaitait pas
utiliser le terme droit bref
donc oui cet amendement a fait bouger
les choses et a fait bouger les lignes
peut-être d'autres choses on fait bouger
aussi parce que parce que c'est comme ça
le débat sur l'IVG aujourd'hui
occupe un peu enfin
quand voilà à la place des retraites ou
à de la guerre il faut quand même voilà
mais voilà on en parle lorsque le texte
a été proposé au Sénat en octobre on en
a parlé on avait eu d'ailleurs on avait
échoué on parlait de droit mais on avait
échoué mais de peu quand on considère le
citron ce qui pour le Sénat est peu
puisque le Sénat est très très très
majoritairement à droite voilà après il
y a eu le texte à l'Assemblée qui a été
voté il faut le rappeler avec une
majorité écrasante de plus de 330 voix
de mémoire ça c'est aussi une forme de
de pression sur sur
ricochet c'est à dire que le décalage
en tant que journaliste ou de
communication politique de dans
l'opinion
une image que ça renvoyait du Sénat par
rapport à l'assemblée peut-être que ça a
pu jouer pas forcément moi j'aimerais
réjouis si ça permet de voilà de rénover
un petit peu l'image du Sénat mais en
tout cas on l'a vu quand même à
l'Assemblée ou le groupe LR a quand même
pour arriver à 330 voix il faut quand
même forcément qu'il y ait des personnes
de droite qui votent il y a des sondages
c'est à dire que moi j'ai aussi utilisé
et compris en commission au stade de la
commission ça n'a pas servi à grand
chose mais plus de 80% des Français sont
favorables à la constitutionnalisation
de l'IVG donc c'est tout
quand on répond à cette question là
est-ce que on répond pas est-ce que vous
êtes favorable à l'IVG vous voyez ce que
je veux dire parce que le sondage est
très complet non c'est très intéressant
c'est un sondage lifop c'est pas
forcément c'est pas totalement des
amateurs et il y avait toute une
batterie de questions
et y compris ça il y avait par par
proximité politique qui avait vous voté
la dernière présidentielle par proximité
ou par conviction religieuse donc
c'était très intéressant parce que on se
rend compte que qu'est-ce qu'on ressent
c'est ce qui était sondage mais au fond
qu'est-ce que traduit ce soutien à la
constitutionnalisation c'est d'une part
l'importance de l'IVG et le fait qu'il
est désormais entré et ancré dans
l'esprit des Français deuxièmement que
quelque part ce droit peut-être menacé
ou remis en question j'ai envie de dire
que ce soit fondé ou non on a des débats
sans fin hier ça bon mais en tout cas
les Français et sans doute les Français
se rendent compte que et ça c'est la
décision américaine qui a tout à coup
fait pour une conscience que c'était
fragile et troisièmement la Constitution
dans l'esprit des gens c'est quand même
un truc qui protège plus quoi c'est bon
et donc du coup sa cheminait vers la
constitutionnalisation plus de 80% des
gens non je dis ça parce que je
j'entends bien à votre question mais il
y a une sénatrice de droite en
commission qui a dit ah mais les gens
ils ont même pas compris la question
qu'on leur posait faut pas forcément
prendre les gens j'ai failli dire ça
mais je me suis repris parce que j'aime
pas du tout ce type de discours mais
même quand on va prendre que pour des
idiots
mais quand même quand on dit intitulé on
peut avoir tendance à répondre
c'est-à-dire que justement c'est pour ça
que je vous fais le dérouler c'est que
je pense que l'idée qui est une
protection supplémentaire puisque c'est
cela qu'on leur dit avec ce message de
constitutionnalisation face à un droit
qui peut-être peut-être remis en cause
parce que ils entendent parler de
l'Italie et puis de la Hongrie et puis
de la Pologne et puis etc c'est quelque
chose donc voilà donc le point positif
c'est l'IVG désormais quelque chose
d'important pour les Français
notamment les sondages est-ce que pour
vous ça justifierait que ce processus
aille jusqu'au référendum ou est-ce que
vous appelez si l'assemblée bien sûr
adopte l'écriture du Sénat est-ce que
vous appelez est-ce que le gouvernement
reprenne la main avec un projet de loi
constitutionnel qui soit voté par le
Congrès qu'est-ce que vous préférez en
termes de Procédure alors peut-être
juste
parce qu'on y reviendra plus tard sur la
question du référendum parce que
Mathilde mais on se garde ça pour un peu
plus tard ça vous va pourquoi le
référendum je trouve que ce sera
intéressant pour conclure ce débat parce
que
la technique parlementaire mais il est
intéressant mais je préfère le garder
pour un peu plus tard parce que je
voudrais qu'on parle de la place de
cette de ce de cette liberté dans la
Constitution je vais vous lire l'article
premier de la Constitution la France est
une République indivisible la Ligue
démocratique et sociale à la sur
l'égalité devant la loi de tous les
citoyens sans distinction d'origine de
race ou de religion elle respecte toutes
les croyances son organisation et
décentralisée et voilà je vous laisse
lire la fin de l'article premier
Jean-Philippe de Rozier
la liberté de la femme de mettre fin à
la grossesse n'est pas inscrite dans cet
article premier mais à l'article 34 vous
trouvez ça logique
ça aurait été quoi trop haut placé dans
l'article premier
justement ça me permet de placer dans le
prolongement de ce que disait
Marie-Pierre de la contrée à l'instant
l'important dans tout ce dans tout cela
c'est la constitutionnalisation la
garantie constitutionnelle de la
possibilité de faire une interruption
volontaire de grossesse et c'est
pourquoi je disais tout à l'heure droit
ou liberté c'est à peu près la même
chose parce qu'il faut s'arrêter sur la
constitutionnalisation de cette
possibilité et je le dis possibilité
pour justement ne pas dire droit ou
liberté que sa figure à l'article 34 ou
à l'article premier sur le plan
constitutionnel sur le plan du droit ça
strictement la même valeur mais sur la
bol mais il y a évidemment une
symbolique dans ce que l'on inscrit au
premier article de la Constitution que
ce que l'on inscrit un peu plus loin et
là c'est dans l'article 34 pour rappeler
à nos téléspectateurs l'article 34 celui
qui est énumère les compétences du
législateur donc c'est pas rien non plus
c'est d'ailleurs été un article était
très discuté au moment de l'élaboration
de la Constitution de la Cinquième
République et c'est un article
fondamental parce que c'est celui qui
dit qu'est-ce qu'il y a dans la loi
qu'est-ce que fait le législateur et
donc là on constitutionnalise la
compétence législative de pouvoir
interrompre sa grossesse le fer figurer
à l'article premier oui pour répondre à
votre question je pense que la
symbolique aurait été trop forte que ce
n'est pas la place de l'article premier
que de reconnaître effectivement toutes
ces droits et ses libertés qui sont
importants je ne veux absolument pas
minimiser l'importance de la liberté de
la femme de disposer son corps et
interrompre sa grossesse mais si on doit
commencer à énumérer toutes les libertés
qui sont importantes on fait un article
premier qui n'en finit plus et il y a
une déclaration des droits de l'homme un
préambule de 1946 qui garantit d'autres
droits et libertés qui sont plutôt
d'ordre sociaux et et ne figure pas non
plus tous à l'article donc il faut
trouver un équilibre une articulation
entre les différents articles de la
Constitution et l'article 34 me paraît
là aussi un bon compromis là-dessus oui
peut-être deux points qui font un peu le
lien avec son Adi auparavant c'est pas
étonnant finalement que le terme de
liberté est moins de charges politiques
à mon sens que le terme de droit parce
que comme vous l'avez dit il y a
évidemment dans le terme de droit cette
cette philosophique l'État doit garantir
et donc on a peur de s'engager dans
quelque chose de revendicatif alors que
la liberté semble tout de suite être un
petit peu plus de l'ordre du personnel
et du Moral etc pareillement deuxième
point je pense qu'on fait perdre un peu
de chat charges symbolique à cette
révision constitutionnelle quand on la
déplace d'articles en articles même si
évidemment on se rejoint ça ne change
absolument rien à sa valeur
constitutionnelle et si je pense qu'il
faut le rappeler quand même l'article
premier n'a évidemment pas cet objet là
il est dans un titre sur l'organisation
de la République donc même quand on y a
ajouté l'égalité entre les hommes et les
femmes voilà la valeur symbolique est
plus grande mais encore une fois en
terme de cohérence on hyper donc je
crois que politiquement le fait de
l'inscrire dans l'artiste 34 au titre
d'une liberté on perd un petit peu en
charge irritante pour les sénateurs les
plus conservateurs même si
constitutionnellement finalement et je
rejoins largement Jean-Philippe de Roger
sur cette question c'est la
l'inscription dans cette ce texte
symbolique et la Constitution dans le
marbre qui qui va donner la garantie
donc liberté plutôt que droit à
l'article 34 c'est aussi une manière de
politiquement un petit peu vider de sa
charge émotionnelle aussi peut-être ce
droit constitutionnel qui de toute façon
aura plein de valeurs à partir du moment
où il est inscrit dans le texte de 58
on va l'évoquer maintenant après le vote
du Sénat la balle elle est dans le camp
du gouvernement oui Thomas si
l'assemblée vote l'écriture choisie par
le Sénat hier ensuite pour être adopté
la proposition de loi constitutionnelle
doit être soumise à référendum une
procédure qui pourrait être simplifiée
si le gouvernement reprenait la main
avec un projet de loi constitutionnel
qu'il a peut simplement être votée par
le Congrès l'assemblée plus le Sénat à
Versailles or l'exécutif se montre
étonnamment plutôt passif dans cette
affaire Elisabeth borne la première
ministre avait exprimé de fortes
convictions à la matière depuis le siège
du planning familial à la fin juin juste
après sa nomination mais elle ne sait
pas saisie du sujet depuis alors certes
il y a d'autres sujets brûlants à
l'agenda mais l'exécutif laisse
globalement faire et s'en remet
systématiquement à une position de
sagesse devant le Parlement et ne prend
donc aucune initiative malgré les
déclarations grandiloquantes mais peu
suivie des faits du garde des sceaux
Eric Dupont-Moretti
inscrire aujourd'hui le droit à l'IVG
dans notre Constitution n'est pas une
mesure gadget un artifice de
communication ou un mouvement de panique
face à un exemple lointain
inscrire le droit à l'IVG cette liberté
fondamentale et inaliénable de la femme
c'est une sécurité pour toutes les
femmes de notre pays alors si c'est
aussi important pourquoi l'exécutif ne
s'engage pas la grande davantage on
pourrait se dire Thomas qu'un pouvoir
qui se revendique progressiste voire
féministe et qui a fait de l'égalité
femme homme la grande cause du premier
et du second quinquennat qui a
panthéonisé Simone Veil veuille
reprendre à son compte cette avancée
symbolique pour le droit et la liberté
des femmes et bien en fait non Emmanuel
Macron se montre ouvert mais reste
totalement en retrait il répond toujours
qu'il est évidemment favorable à l'IVG à
l'avortement mais c'est un oui mais une
approbation toujours
balancer et nuancer par le je cite
traumatisme des femmes qui avortent
Emmanuel Macron était d'ailleurs on le
rappelle contre l'allongement du délai
de recours à l'IVG de 12 à 14 semaines
qui a été adopté en février son ancien
premier ministre Jean Castex y était
aussi défavorable c'est Christophe
Castaner à l'époque qui était le chef
des députés marcheurs qu'il avait imposé
à l'agenda politique poussé par sa
majorité et au niveau européen l'action
d'Emmanuel Macron Emmanuel Macron a
voulu pousser le sujet dans la Charte
des droits fondamentaux mais là encore
on sait que les pays ne sont pas tous
d'accord donc le processus est très
complexe et risque de ne pas forcément
aboutir on entend désormais du côté de
l'exécutif que l'IVG dans la
Constitution pourrait faire partie d'une
réforme plus large consacrée aux
institutions ces prochains mois bref
Emmanuel Macron semble procrastiner sur
ce sujet il faut savoir qu'il se rend
souvent au Vatican qu'il soigne sa
relation avec le Pape cette même
hésitation sur l'avortement existe sur
un autre sujet associéal celui de
l'euthanasie et c'est stop and go
permanent contribue plus globalement à
brouiller son message et le sens de sa
politique sur le sujet merci Mathilde
Marie-Pierre delagonie vous allez
pouvoir répondre à la question que
posait Mathilde tout à l'heure elle est
mais voilà elle est beaucoup plus
nourrie par cette par cette situation
elle est nourrie par l'éditorial de
Mathis le gouvernement vous laisse
là-bas Emmanuel Macron du sondage qui
montre que 80% de catholique pratiquants
sont quand même favorables à la
constitutionnalisation de l'IVG
il y a deux voix possibles j'ai envie de
dire quel que soit le cheminement
parlementaire donc pas trop entrer dans
les détails mais bref
référendum au Congrès nous c'est
extrêmement simple nous ne redoutons
rien y compris le référendum parce que
80% des Français sont sont favorables
moi ça ne me paraît pour de la part
d'Emmanuel Macron pas totalement sensé
s'il s'engageait dans cette voie parce
que aujourd'hui on se bat sur des
retraites en l'occurrence contre
concernant le camp politique il y a des
sujets lourds et il a une solution qui
est assez simple pour arriver
à constitutionnaliser Jules donc on
n'est pas obligé de passer par le
référendum obligé si le gouvernement
reprend la main le Congrès oui mais
c'est Éric Dupond-Moretti hier nous a
fait des commentaires très très
enthousiastes sur le principe mais les
rédactions ne vont jamais j'avais
l'impression je l'écoutais son discours
est très intéressant mais on avait
l'impression de voir un examinateur en
train de corriger une copie du Bac
c'est-à-dire qu'il est ministre garde
des sceaux il faudrait qu'il propose une
rédaction il y a une façon de faire très
simple que je lui propose il prend les
10 personnes qui se sont investies sur
ce sujet il les met autour de la table
et je vous fiche mon billet que une
demi-journée après il y a une rédaction
consensuelle entre l'Assemblée et le
Sénat qui peut faire un projet de loi
qui sera voté par les deux assemblées
non mais évitez je vous dis nous on le
redoute pas mais moi je vais vous dire
pourquoi éviter parce que éviter si un
référendum on sait ce qui va se passer
pardon nous interrompre le camp de de
des antivégés bah ça va être une tribune
généralisée donc c'est bien pour ça que
ça ne nous sommes pas très raisonnable
par ailleurs ça coûte de l'argent à
l'état de faire un référendum ça veut
dire une campagne etc donc si manuel
Macron trouve que c'est une bonne idée
de faire ça très bien en tout cas ce que
je veux dire c'est voilà nous ne le
redoutons pas mais nous pensons que ce
n'est pas très sensé en revanche il y a
un processus très simple qui s'appelle
le Congrès on a déjà réuni le Congrès
pour écouter le président de la
République on peut peut-être le réunir
alors par ailleurs dire on va faire une
grande réforme institutionnelle pour
voilà c'est un truc classique pour dire
on verra plus tard etc et votre
parallèle avec la fin de vie et tout à
fait judicieux c'est à dire qu'on est
sur la fin de vie nous avions un travail
trans partisan qui fait que nous avons
quel que soit les camps politiques nous
avions défini des textes qui étaient
voilà j'ai toujours avec des pas été un
petit peu voilà mais nous étions
d'accord et c'est quand même lui qui a
fait que le sujet n'aboutit pas moi je
ne m'explique pas cet ambivalace mais ça
fait un certain temps que je n'essaye
plus de comprendre Emmanuel Macron parce
que je dois pas avoir le bon logiciel
unchard desinapho on va pas faire un
rappel de tous les référendums mais bon
c'est toujours un risque pour le pouvoir
en place un référendum oui alors là on
est dans un homme qui est particulier
puisque c'est n'est pas un homme
d'initiative Immo ministérielle ou
intellectuellement du président donc on
pourrait se dire que la tendance des
Français à répondre OUI ou NON au
gouvernement en place pour être tempéré
dans le sens où c'est plutôt une
proposition parlementaire donc ça serait
un peu du hors sujet on l'a dit il y a
aussi un consensus populaire autour de
cette question qui est une avancée des
droits fondamentaux néanmoins on peut se
dire aussi que il y aura quelque chose
d'assez gênant à réentendre des proshoïs
et des prolife en France donc si c'est
vraiment une avancée sociétale peut-être
qu'on pourrait estimer que le consensus
est suffisamment grand pour obtenir le
Congrès mais il y a aussi ce risque de
considérer toujours que le référendum
est un risque et d'installer aussi ça
m'imaginaire populaire si le référendum
ne fait pas peur au parlementaire au
président pourquoi ne pas finalement y
aller la seule chose c'est est-ce que
c'est l'outil adéquate pour adopter
cette proposition néanmoins comme vous
le dites pour en arriver au projet il
faut une adhésion de la majorité et on
sent bien vous l'avez parfaitement
résumé que il y a une forte hésitation
voire même quelque chose qui relève de
l'abandon en fait de politique en
considérant que il y a un voilà de la
majorité gouvernementale vous avez tout
à fait raison du gouvernement
c'est-à-dire que on soutient mais on
voit bien qu'on n'est pas dans une
mécanique de reprise en main par par le
gouvernement donc je ne sais pas si ça
sera vraiment une option choisie par le
gouvernement l'idée aussi de la
proposition de loi constitutionnelle qui
aboutit au référendum ce serait quand
même l'inédit sous la Cinquième
République c'est-à-dire qu'on aurait
enfin une proposition de loi
constitutionnelle qui arriverait à faire
consensus entre les deux assemblées qui
seraient soumises au peuple appelons
quand même que c'est un petit peu aussi
l'initiative normale dans le texte de
notre article 89 donc ça pourrait être
joli pour les constitutionnalistes pour
être une l'histoire aussi pour notre
référendum la démission gouvernementale
sur le sujet et ça c'est la vérité le
gouvernementale et présidentielle aussi
puisqu'on le sait ça fait partie
évidemment des dossiers compétences
Jean-Philippe de rosier avec le groupe
de réflexion sur l'évolution de la
Constitution et des institutions vous
allez travailler vous avez lancé sable
je crois qu'il y a un semestre prévu
pour ensuite faire des propositions pour
moderniser les procédures d'élaboration
de la loi il y a des leçons à tirer de
la séquence qu'on est en train de de
vivre
oui il y a toujours des leçons à tirer
du débat constitutionnel et c'est pour
ça que je disais tout à l'heure que le
débat constitutionnel est important et
que toujours judicieux de s'en saisir et
donc nous nous en sommes saisis dans le
cadre du grequis comme vous l'avez
justement rappelé pour réfléchir à la
façon de d'élaborer la loi et au rôle
des différentes institutions aussi plus
largement à la place du président de la
République à la place de de l'exécutif
face au pouvoir législatif et comme le
dit très justement Marie-Pierre de la
Gontrie si jamais cette proposition de
loi constitutionnelle aller jusqu'au
bout de le processus à elle c'est à dire
au référendum ce serait
je ne sais pas si c'est une démission du
gouvernement sur le sujet mais en tout
cas ce sera une mise à l'écart du
gouvernement sur le sujet il y a quatre
acteurs dans une procédure de révision
constitutionnelle le président de la
République les deux assemblées et le
peuple et ce serait la première fois que
une révision serait adoptée avec trois
de ses acteurs qui n'incluent pas le
président de la République parce que on
a déjà eu le peuple une fois en 2000
avec le quinquennat d'habitude c'est le
président et les deux assemblées de leur
côté et là ce serait la première fois
que le pouvoir exécutif n'intervient
pratiquement pas et ce serait donc perçu
comme une sorte de de rejet enfin en
creux absolument alors avec le
gouvernement serait serait assez en
retrait mais d'un autre côté aller au
référendum ça a été rappelé également
effectivement les parlementaires ne le
craignent pas c'est risqué c'est risqué
parce que sans faire l'inventaire des de
tous les référendums d'ailleurs il n'a
pas eu il y en a pas eu 50 il y en a eu
10 sous la Cinquième République et
depuis 1969 chaque référendum s'est
traduit soit par un désintérêt total de
la population soit par un séisme qui
dans tous les cas le premier ou le
deuxième fait trembler le pouvoir en
place c'est-à-dire l'exécutif parce que
si les Français oui bah c'était un
séisme c'était un séisme la victoire du
nom à placer la France dans une position
pour le moins délicate au regard des
relations internationales par la suite
effectivement il a été surmonté ce qui
prouve effectivement les poursuites et
les répliques du séisme et et et
lorsque en 2000 les Français ne vont pas
voter
marquant leur désintérêt total vis-à-vis
de en 2000 c'était le quinquennat bon
bah pareil ça montre que finalement tout
ça pour ça fallait-il mobiliser les
Français engagés engagé les moyens de
l'État pour organiser le référendum donc
c'est quand même risqué que d'emprunter
cette voie en plus de la tribune que ça
va offrir aux Antilles avortement dans
le débat public alors il y a cette
question de vous avez commencé à
l'évoquer du comparatif avec avec
d'autres pays d'Europe et effectivement
du du risque IVG n'est pas menacé en
France on entend souvent ça je propose à
Mathias ça reste de nouveau de nous
rejoindre rebons sur Mathias
cet argument l'IVG n'est pas me dater en
France et évidemment il fait beaucoup
réagir et oui c'est un argument qui fait
sauter au plafond les défenseurs des
droits des femmes comme Sylvie Pierre
Brossolette présidente du Haut Conseil à
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
écoutez là personne ne peut prédire
l'avenir par définition et il y a des
mouvements à l'oeuvre un peu
réactionnaires dans le monde entier les
droits des femmes et les droits sexuels
et reproductifs sont mis en danger en
échec en Europe même regarder ce qui se
passe en Pologne les femmes réfugiées du
crâne qui ont été enceintes à la suite
d'un viol des armées russes n'ont même
pas le droit de se faire avorter c'est à
quelques milliers de kilomètres de chez
nous on n'est jamais à l'abri qu'un
mouvement d'opinion puisse amener une
majorité au style donc il faut assurer
ses arrières et tant qu'on le peut
puisqu'il y a un consensus du pays
profiter de ce consensus pour mettre à
l'abri le droit à l'IVG alors on va
regarder comment ça se passe dans
d'autres pays maintenant absolument
Sylvie Pierre Brossolette en parle la
Pologne pays membres de l'Union
européenne ou le droit d'avortement
était autorisé et gratuit depuis 1956 en
est revenu depuis 2020 ce droit n'est
plus garanti que dans deux circonstances
grossesse résultant d'un acte illégal ou
un risque pour la vie de la maman depuis
2021 il est même interdit d'avorter en
cas de malformation grave et
irréversible du foetus ou de maladies
incurables potentiellement mortelle pour
le foetus autre exemple outre-Atlantique
l'abrogation de l'arrêt roversus way de
par la Cour suprême des États-Unis avant
protéger au niveau fédéral le droit
d'avorter dépend aujourd'hui de la loi
de chaque État une vingtaine d'entre eux
déjà interdit où ont prévu de le faire
et alors dans quel pays cela pourrait
évoluer et bien là Hongrie l'autorise
depuis 1953 mais tente chaque fois plus
de mètres des bâtons dans les roues de
l'IVG en 1992 la loi apporte une
protection de la vie fœtale faisant
diminuer le nombre de recours à
l'avortement et depuis septembre 2022
dans la Hongrie de Victor Hormann il est
désormais obligatoire pour chaque femme
souhaitant pratiquer un avortement
d'écouter les battements du cœur du
foetus dernier exemple de l'autre côté
des Alpes en Italie là-bas la présidente
du conseil des ministres Giorgia Meloni
n'a pas ouvertement dit qu'elle
souhaitait revenir sur l'IVG cependant
celle qui décrit l'avortement comme une
défaite souhaite multiplier les
solutions financières et sociales pour
permettre aux femmes de garder leur
enfant merci Mathias uncharling bezinas
est-ce que la Constitution
protège d'un retour en arrière vous
voyez ce que je veux dire si on se place
dans une dans une dans une hypothèse ou
voilà
pouvoir changerait en France et
voudraient remettre en cause le droit à
l'avortement alors oui et non oui parce
que la Constitution elle a cette
rigidité que nous avons souhaité en 58
qui consiste à rendre sa procédure de
révision toujours plus complexe qu'une
simple révision du noir ordinaire donc
touché à la constitution c'est plus
compliqué néanmoins non parce que un
pouvoir majoritaire les généralement
suffisamment pour pouvoir faire adopter
une révision de la Constitution alors là
en l'occurrence ça serait pas tout à
fait le cas du pouvoir en place mais bon
voilà c'est toujours possible et puis on
l'a dit c'est un droit qui ne peuvent
être garanti complètement par la
Constitution puisqu'il faut forcément
des lois voire même des textes
réglementaires d'application il faut des
médecins sur le terrain et on peut tout
à fait imaginer malheureusement qu'un
régime qui ne souhaite plus mettre de
moyens là-dedans qu'il soit désinciter
ce type de politique puisse toujours le
restreindre sans forcément revenir sur
la Constitution
elle-même donc garantir la Constitution
alors normalement c'est une du
législateur mais encore faut-il imaginer
des recours constitutionnels et on l'a
bien vu dans tous ces pays-là on gris
Pologne les cours constitutionnels
elles-mêmes sont complètement
marginalisées ou aux mains du pouvoir
donc la politique fiction du pied pourri
nous amener très loin ce pourquoi voilà
la formulation garantie des choses
évidemment symbolise mais ne permet pas
forcément toujours d'aller d'aller plus
dans plus de garantie par rapport à un
retour en arrière oui deux choses c'est
que d'abord le processus de révision
constitutionnel amène à des majorités
qui me semble-t-il vont au delà
simplement d'une victoire législative
majoritaire simple puisqu'il faut une
majorité particulière donc ça protège un
peu plus ça c'est c'est la première
chose la deuxième chose vous avez raison
c'est à dire que dès lors que ça renvoie
une loi et c'est normal la loi peut très
bien très strictive mais je pense que le
gain essentiel
par rapport à ce scénario noir c'est la
dépénalisation c'est à dire dans la
Constitution il est dit liberté de la
femme etc etc ça veut dire que au fond
dans le pire des scénarios on ne
pourrait pas revenir à une pénalisation
de l'interruption de grossesse je suis
peut-être peu ambitieuse mais par
rapport au raisonnement qui est juste
c'est à dire que demain un autre pouvoir
pourrait décider par une loi que l'IVG
c'est jusqu'à je sais pas trois semaines
que bon mais pas la pénalisation et
c'est quand même
ça a été le l'origine même de la loi
veille ça a été d'abord la
dépénalisation
oui bon dans le prolongement de tout
cela le Conseil constitutionnel est
vigilant lorsqu'il examine des lois à ne
pas empiéter sur le domaine du
législateur c'est à dire que c'est lui
le législateur qui décide des politiques
publiques qui décident de l'orientation
politique à la législation qu'il adopte
en revanche le Conseil constitutionnel
est vigilant à ce que les mesures prises
par le législateur les lois adoptées ne
prive pas c'est sa formule de garantie
légale une exigence constitutionnelle et
donc en reconnaissant cette liberté de
mettre un terme à sa grossesse
effectivement il y a là un point
d'interrogation à ce stade et on n'a pas
là on n'a pas la réponse est-ce que
c'est simplement considéré que la femme
sera toujours libre d'interrompre sa
grossesse et donc on ne pourra pas
revenir à la pénalisation comme le
disait madame de la contrée à l'instant
est-ce que ça garantit une liberté
d'interrompre jusqu'à un certain temps
sa grossesse et que si on en revient à
un délai de trois semaines qui en
réalité il revient à dire que l'IVG
n'est plus possible
ça en réalité ce serait
inconstitutionnel aux yeux du Conseil
constitutionnel parce qu'il n'y aurait
pas suffisamment de garantie légale pour
cette exigence constitutionnelle là la
jurisprudence peut-être aura l'occasion
de le dire à l'avenir je ne l'espère pas
parce que ça voudrait dire que le
législateur ce serait emparé du sujet
pour remettre en cause cette
IVG mais voilà où on en est il n'y a pas
pour dire les choses simplement
d'obligation pour le législateur à
intervenir y compris dans un domaine qui
est constitutionnellement garanti mais
le Conseil constitutionnel veille à ce
que lorsque le législateur est intervenu
il n'y ait pas un retour en arrière qui
remet en cause une garantie qu'il a
apporté un dernier mot maire de la
ganterie est-ce que on a cité les pays
où finalement ce droit l'avortement
était en péril est-ce que c'est pas
aussi un symbole que la France renvoie à
l'Europe en disant ben nous au contraire
on protège encore plus si mais peut-être
que les deux éminents
constitutionnalistes sur ce plateau des
mentirons si je me trompe mais je crois
que nous serions le premier pays à
inscrire le droit le droit en tout cas à
l'IVG dans une constitution donc oui
bien sûr c'est un signal fort alors on
nous a beaucoup
critiqué voire moquer en disant la
Constitution n'est pas là pour envoyer
des signes des signaux très bien mais
oui ce serait un signal fort bien sûr
parce que vous savez enfin c'est des
c'est des comment dire
les féministes dans le monde entier se
battent et Dieu sait si ce n'est pas en
France qui pour l'instant c'est plus
difficile on voit partout l'Iran etc
donc oui bien sûr c'est un signe
d'espoir merci beaucoup merci à tous
d'avoir participé à ce à ce débat je
vous dis à demain pour un nouveau ah non
on est jeudi donc à lundi pour un
nouveau numéro de sciences publiques moi
j'adore cette émission je suis prête à
la faire un jour de plus en tout cas
votre prochain rendez-vous politique sur
notre antenne Oriane morcenis qui reçoit
Aurélie trouver dans la matinale la
députée elle est fille de
Seine-Saint-Denis belle soirée